mr. Jung
mr. scowl and to all of the members of
the Nobel Committee ladies and gentlemen
it is impossible to begin this lecture
without again expressing my deep
appreciation to the Nobel Committee of
the Norwegian Parliament for bestowing
upon me and the civil rights movement in
the United States such a great honor
occasionally in life that of those
moments of unutterable fulfillment which
cannot completely be explained by those
symbols called words their meaning can
only be articulated by the inaudible
language of the heart and such as the
moment I am presently experiencing I
experienced this high and joyous moment
not for myself alone but for those
devotees of non-violence who have moved
so courageously against around pots of
racial injustice and who in the process
have acquired a new estimate of their
own human worth